the ethiopian government says that it
has recaptured two towns which
previously had fallen to the militants
from the tigre region the warring
parties have now been fighting for a
year the conflict has cost thousands of
lives and is threatening to escalate
a nobel peace prize winner at the head
of an army ethiopian prime minister abi
ahmed encouraged his troops to destroy
tigrayan forces
you are heroes but you don't know that
you are the country is there because of
you
you are the ones keeping ethiopia's
existence as a country
tigray and youth are falling like leaves
they should know that they have been
defeated and surrendered
this came after ahmed called on all
citizens to take up arms to fight the
tigrayan people's liberation front
people in the capital addis ababa showed
up in droves
for weeks the tplf and its allies have
been battling close to the city
part of a wider offensive that's gone
far beyond the tigray region
diplomatic efforts are in high gear
last month the u.s got involved with
secretary of state anthony blinken on
his first african mission
we'd like to see the parties come
together at the table to put in place a
cessation of hostilities
we need to see humanitarian assistance
flow freely
now
we need to see people detained
released
but china is also involving itself the
foreign minister flew to ethiopia to
express his support for the government
we understand the situation in ethiopia
very well ethiopia has the history
acumen and capacity to solve this
problem we also want the problem to be
solved there this way
bringing the two sides together will be
anything but easy
the war has killed thousands and
displaced more than two million people a
state of emergency is in effect in the
capital and citizen patrols allegedly
supported by the government roam the
streets at night looking for tplf
sympathizers
human rights organizations and the
united nations say there have been
widespread abuses on both sides
meanwhile with passions running high in
the capital the u.s and several european
countries have called on their citizens
in ethiopia to leave a sign of less than
total faith that peace negotiations will
succeed
and for more now we want to bring in
coletta juan johy she's a journalist
based in nairobi she knows the tigray
region very well and she's been
following this conflict closely coletta
it's good to have you on the program you
know we're hearing from the ethiopian
government that they've won several key
battles
does this tell us that they're able to
protect the capital or do they have the
chance of winning back control of the
tigray region
the news is very significant for the
federal government because we know some
of these areas that the prime minister
says he has been able to recapture from
the tplf are very close to the to the
capital city uh the two of them most i
mean that really caused a lot of tension
recently and made many people leave
especially foreigners um thinking that
the capital would fall some of them are
just about 400 kilometers away from the
capital city so yes it is significant
the government has gone ahead to say
that the prime minister has gone to the
war fund in a bid to not only protect
the capital city but also push back the
tplf back into the northern region
because they were advancing towards uh
the capital city so yes it is strategic
and quite symbolic showing that the
government is really working to ensure
that the capital is safe
and yet we hear from the the tigray
fighters as you said the tplf they
insist that they still have the upper
hand in this conflict
why are they saying that if it's not
true
i guess during a war uh every every
every party has to defend itself has to
project itself because they all have
supporters there are ethiopians who
support the tplf there and there are
other ethiopians who support the federal
government forces you see so on the
efforts so the tplf has been said that
they're just moving away strategically
but the government insists that they are
pushing them away militarily so yes it
is probably as a reason for them to to
real uh to continue ramping up support
from this i mean from their supporters
and ensuring that they keep that morale
that they have kept throughout the the
fighting and coletta we want to let our
viewers know you were one of the few
journalists allowed into the tigray
region earlier this year
what is life like for the people there
when we went there the war was still
very young quote-unquote you know it was
still very young into the war it was
around march and uh i believe that the
same factors that we saw then still
count right now it's about displacement
it's about people being very desperate
people living then they were living in
classrooms because they've been forced
out of their homes we had women and
children who talked about having been um
sexually molested um the human i mean
the human human rights workers there
were telling us these are cases that
they are getting mental
i mean disability because of the war was
still a factor and we we know the united
nations is still talking about food
insecurity especially for the affected
the numbers have grown they are now
talking about over nine million people
who might need emergency food assistance
so the factors that were there then are
still being projected now by the united
nations by the ethiopia human rights
commission and other agencies that are
working closely with the people so
desperation is what i would call all
these especially for those who've been
directly affected by the conflict yeah
which makes it all the more important
that journalists such as yourself are
able to get into the region and to get
that truth out to the world journalist
coletta won joey joining us tonight from
nairobi coletta thank you
thank you
you